*weird swedish sounds*
Hello hello, sweetheart!
(Hej hej på dig, hjärtat!)
Would you fucking look at that!
(Det var som fan!)
YoU lAuGh YoU LoSe
(SKRatTAr dU fÖRloRAr Du)
(whispering) Let's do this!
(Nu kör vi!)
You laugh 👏 👏
You lose 👏 👏
YouTube's favorite show everybody
Smash that like button right now to join in on the challenge.
Yes, That's the only way you can watch this video
and make sure you smash twice and to subscribe.
Smash that like button to subscribe right now to this channel.
(some legit fortnite dancing)
Oh, that's so great
I think we show this one, I'm not sure
It's subtle
* 'deja vu' music box cover*
Oh, man
I didn't get it the first time I saw it.
I'm like I don't- what's the big deal?
*regular sounds of music box*
* 'deja vu' music box cover*
Ohh.. Me and Marzia will get that for our wedding that's beautiful
(shrieks)
What the hell is this?
*Incessant chicken-like gobbling*
Please stop. Okay not interested
*oh, not again*
Stop!
*coo cooo*
wuwhuuwhat I didn't say anything!
*COOOOO*
wHaT ThE hElL?
People pay to watch this?
Are you kidding me?
I do it for free! Okay? What the heck, dude?
*tick tock tick tock*
*enters gates of hell*
Oh My Gahd
I don't, I'M NOT GONNA
I don't care you copy striked my video (AliNiTy)
Its not my fault! You brought this upon yourself!
Okay?
It's all your fault
No, no, no, I gave you a chance to apologize
oh my god
There's no reasoning in you
Jesus Christ
PFFT
That seems like a great show, would love to watch that
That would just be
ffaannnaabbbtics
The Netherlands is going to the semi finals (Nederland gaat in de halve finale komen)
I suddenly have a feeling we are going to the semi finals (trust me it's dutch)
Ball possession for Frank De Boer
*shots fired*
Good old modern warfare quickscope everyb-
THEREISBEARCUM|THEREISBEARCUM+ALCP<<{ASCTHEREISBEARCUMCAPIJSCNPA
OHOHSOHOHSOCHAOHSCLSNOCNHSAIH
*dutch noises*
Anomaly screaming "MY D*** IS SO HARD! OOOOOH"    in Swedish
*swedish noise*
Why is there Swedish in there?
Are the swedes trying to infiltrate this show,
"Skrattar du förlorar du"?
(TRANSLATION COMING UP)
My cock is hard that is bear cum everybody hello?
My cock is so hard there is bear cum everybody. Hello.
My cock is so hard there is bear cum everybody. Hello. I am a Swedish
I am a Swedish
There is (björn kom?)
(bear cum)
That is byon come (??)
Cum, come?
DE Ä BJÖRNKOM!
DE Ä BJÖRNKOOOOOOOOM
All women,
*Unsheathes lightsaber*
ARE KWEENS
IF She BreAtHeS,
SHE'S A THOOOOOOOOTTTT
WHAT???
I CANNOT believe he just said that word.
Did he... DID HE JUST SAID the T-word?? the T word? (I totally agree vice, uh, i mean pewds)
THE T-WORD?
*unbelievable!!!*
No! The foulest of all words. This can't be right. I must find this video immediately (yes vice)
All women, ARE KWEENS
All waHmEN are kWeEns
*inhales deeply*
If she breathes,
SHE'S A THOOOOOOOOOOTTTT
*screams*
*poods dying*
Oh, that's so good!
-I mean that's so awful
If sHe brEAthEs . . .  SHE'S A THOOOOOOOOOOTTTT
AAAARRRGRGGGRGR
*Pewds giggles*
Uuh... basically left and right politics summarized right here
aLL waHmEN are kWeEns
*laughs*
*PewNews everybody*
Excuse me, Gloria Borger here. I don't understand how Pewdiepie could think THOT was a memeable word
ayeyaye
That's completely beyond me. How dare he? How dare he- he used such foul language
It's not like people using jokingly without a bad connotation all the time. Doesn't make any sense
"The recoil bruised my shoulder.
The brass shell casings disoriented me as they flew past my face..."
This is an article!!
"the smells..."
This is a real article!
"sulfur and destruction made me sick.
The explosions loud like a bomb gave me a temporary case of PTSD"
Ooh
"For at least an hour after firing the gun just a few times I was anxious and irritable
*annoying af pewds*
hE wAs AnXIoUs aNd iRriTAbLe
Can you imagine gave you PTSD?
"...a temporary form of PTSD"
Temporary form. The dumbest thing I've ever heard to make up like...
shooting a gun gave you temporary PTSD if you've never been in a war
It makes absolutely no sense.
Oh my God, I've seen this!
Spoilers guys, spoilers
Pikachu: Pika
Pikachu,
Why won't you get in your pokeball? ( ͡~ ͜ʖ ͡°)
Its because... it's because... I always want to be with you
*NANI??*
I love the guy that cracks up l-listen to his laugh. It's like a serio-heh-us moment
listen
I can only imagine the discussions they must have had internally about the fact that Pikachu all of the sudden
out of nowhere just to- decides to communicate in English
iT's bEcAUsE
*hysterical AAAAAAHHAAAAHA*
I like how it's all adults in the cinema as well watching this kids movie
WHAT THE FRICK GUYS Pikachu doesn't talk!!!
You're using offence as your shield
It's a DEfence. D + fence = DEFENSE
COME ON SAY IT
Oh, she's hot
Damn, why didn't I say it?
COME ON
YOU CAN DO IT
it's just a girl
just a person like you
It's a good joke
SHE'S GONNA LAUGH
COME ON ARE YOU LOSING THIS OPPORTUNITY?
what's the worst thing that gonna happen?
She's gonna like you
COME ON YOUCANDOIT
SAY IT!!!
It's a defense
*laughs*
yes...
*awkward*
*sad*
*silence*
*criiiinge*
It's a defense.
*👏 👏 meme review*
Everyone press F on their keyboards right now please
Alright, let's- let's check the patch notes for uh
(poods: huh, so hot in here)
the sims 3
"Kleptomaniac Sims can no longer steal subway stations from lots. Sims can no longer whoo-hoo and in the elevator with a
sim who's on a different floor
The grim reaper will no longer be prevented from reaping souls due to band affiliation.
Fixed a tuning issues so that Sims now... *wheeze*
...vomit at acceptable levels
*wheezing*
It is no longer possible to try for baby
*wheezing while saying* With a grim reaper
Become enemies with a child wish no longer appears
Sims who are on fire will no longer be forced to
*wheeze* attend graduation before they can put themselves out
Oof
Sims will no longer recieve a wish to 'skinny-dip' with mummies
A meteor can hit a building which case everyone will run out before the collision those who do not exit the building will die
Sims automatically leave if a meteor is approaching unless it is a school
*wheeze* in which children are not allowed to leave and
WHAA-AAA-AAT
WILL ALWAYS DIE
*WHEEZE*
aww..
This sims patch note, that's brilliant
'When you forget you don't have a floor in your room'
BWAHHHHHHHH
*BOOM*
Great. Fantastic.
Well, I heard a floor. So I don't know what this meme is all about.
WELL EVERYBODY 👏 👏 👏
That's 👏 Skrattar Duuuuu 👏 - Förlorar Duuuu
maNAnaneaeeenn
Hope you guys enjoyed this video. If you did make sure to hit that Bell
*BING*
Make sure to crank it into gear from one to six in the right order
Make sure 👏 - wait, waaaait....
(BONUS LAUGHS)
*BING*
*well sh*t*
*thought i was done*
and dont forget to SUBSCRIBE
So Make sure to smash that bell, yank that lever, twist that knob, pull that rug, flip that switch
Aerate that garage touch that dial and you don't touch that dial peel that film drop that eyedropper and subsequently
fill that tube scrape that tongue borrow that leap floor from urban exercise that melanoma fondle that sand paper
jam
that zipper scroll past those recommended
Conspiracy videos pass that ketchup smell those roses board that chip and jump free that four squeeze that fat burn
Hibernate those penguins and like and subscribe and comment for the algorithm nation
"Ball pit kissing prank h3h3 MMA match
Vs. Jacksepticeye
AND MORE..."
Incredible!
Well, I really like how YouTube makes the system so simple- to find videos of the Creators that you enjoy
Another testimony was I supposed to end the video?
*yes*
*outro*
*but can you this?*
*bye*
*broderfist*